and this is southern alberta the rcmp
are trying to clear a blockade at a busy
border crossing into the u.s police
announced earlier today that they
decided that blockade by protesters
angry about vaccine mandates and public
health restrictions is no longer lawful
and they moved in the protest by
truckers farmers and others have stopped
the flow of goods and people across the
border for four days and trapped some
truckers who don't support it our
heather urix west has been at the scene
all day heather alberta's premier just
spoke to the media he again called the
protest unacceptable what else did he
say
well donna he began by expressing some
support for those who were participating
in lawful protests against vaccine
mandates for for truckers he said that
he in his recent trip to washington that
he was looking for allies to find an
exemption for unvaccinated
cross-border truckers who didn't
so they shouldn't have to quarantine but
he went on to call this blockade illegal
and unacceptable he urged protesters
to to quit and he also called for calm
after
several disturbing reports of violence
involving protesters within the last
couple of hours
i have also received reports
in the last hour of people allied with
the protesters assaulting rcmp officers
including in one instance trying to ram
members of the rcmp
later leading to a collision with a
civilian vehicle this kind of conduct is
totally unacceptable
heather the blockade is still in place
though the rcmp still there any sign of
a resolution soon
no in fact we have about a hundred
still blockading the road and
from what we can see it seems as though
our cmp have pulled pulled back we're
not seeing the helicopter circling um
we're not seeing the same kind of
presence that we were seeing a couple of
hours ago but we have seen new
police enforcements arrive just a short
time ago we saw
five police cars from the lethbridge
police service arrive
more vehicles from canadian border
services agency so while we don't have
an official update on the rcmp's plans
this evening
this is still a very fluid situation and
one that we will of course be continuing
to watch in the hours and days
ahead all right heather urich's west in
coots alberta thanks